bonjour je m'appelle Armelle je suis
responsable du salon de coiffure Franck
Provost à Saint-Denis nous nous trouvons
donc désormais rue MacAuliffe plein
centre de Saint-Denis actuellement nous
sommes 8 personnes au salon nous sommes
trois coiffeurs
et une coloriste
le salon est passé sur l'ancienne Franck
Provost depuis peu ça fait à peu près un
an
pour compléter notre équipe nous
recherchons un coiffeur une coiffeuse
coloriste dynamique passionnée avec un
excellent relationnel et expérimenté de
niveau brevet professionnel avec
quelques années d'expérience vous
souhaitez intégrer notre salon n'hésitez
pas contactez-nous